hello everyone and welcome back to the
pop gems championship I'm just kidding
welcome to chess table masters this is
the first game we'll be showing and it's
it's a third leg of the Magnus
Invitational which is of the Magnus
Chester which is a 1 million dollar
dollar tournament and this is the third
event so it's 12 of the world's
strongest players they will be rolling
it out first in the preliminaries where
everyone will face off against everyone
in the wrong group and then we go to the
knockout stages of the tournament but
we're going to go through that after we
cover some games now first game we're
going to show is spent on Hari Krishna
versus Magnus Carlsen really already a
thriller and before we check out the
game just to very small announcements I
got not only no made a new video so if
you haven't seen it do check it out it
will be the first link in the
description below sort of a compilation
of some weird moments on the channel
there are well some are funny some are
just weird but they do check it out if
you haven't seen it and also second
thing I would like to congratulate yours
out of chest Channel on reaching 10,000
subscribers there you have it
yesterday on my stream he he played the
game against a murder a job of and it
was it was quite the game if you haven't
seen it do check it out he made an
analysis of the game I will put a link
to it also in the description below will
be the second link you will see so check
it out if you haven't now getting back
to the game Hari Krishna with the white
pieces opens with E 4 and like 95% of
the times when you play against Magnus
that means we are going to have a
Sicilian on the board so c5 by Magnus
India just since this is the first game
we're covering the format of the
tournament is 15 minutes per player and
already you have a 10 second increment
starting from move 1 so every move 10
seconds you get an increment so neither
of three we have Knight to c6 sorry
about that
and now you strike in the center with d4
so adjust normal stuff characters
captures and now 90 to f6 we have Knight
to c3 and of course magnus goes for his
'if i've the Pelican the last car
Sicilian this fashion called Sicilian
wear whatever you call it nowadays
Knight beat the d5 and now d6 just
preventing Knight to d6 check with
Bishop to g5 in here
six by Magnus so all very standard and
the opening is a very long theoretical
struggle so now now I here you go either
you go back or you capture here
you cannot capture with the Queen
because of 97 check picks up the rook
but black is very happy to capture with
the Jeep on here you would then have a
nice advancement to f5 so tonight back
to a3 consider the strongest we have b5
now threatening b4 to win one of the
Knights and now Knight to d5 so still
very standard stuff we have brush up to
e7 and now Bishop captures on f6 the
most-played move here at Bishop captures
and the c4 now I did some studying on
this fresh new coat and usually what a
black doesn't really gain anything by
advancing the pawn to b4 as a white will
be very happy in shifting this night
over to e3 and from there you will again
have access to d5 into f5 however every
position is different so here it it
could be okay so here b4 we have night
the c2 with the idea of shifting the
night at e3 and now a 5 as the b4 point
is attacked twice for the moment so a 5
and now g3 preparing to have Finn get to
the lights were Bishop we have g6 Magnus
wants to talk back his bishop into g7
and now Hari Krishna it just grabs it so
Knight captures we have Queen captures
and Bishop to g2
now both players Castle to safety we
have castles by Magnus castles by Hari
Krishna and Bishop the b7 also I heard
that they call sometimes hide accretion
hurricane Harry
if anyone can confirm that I would be
very happy
and here Queen to d2 we have Knights the
b8 now nice to be 8 with the idea of
shifting the night over to c5 and from
c5 you will put a lot of pressure on e4
and since the bishop already a taxi for
could be very good for black also white
might have to weaken the further his
King side by playing f3 and here there
is one game where Knights the e3 was
played with the plain idea of just
bringing the Knight to d5 however here
are the conditional plays rook F 2 d1
and it is already as of move 18 that we
have a completely new game so calling
this game of theoretical struggle would
definitely
be an understatement but yeah new new
move look after d1 and now you're
threatening to pick up Carlson's d6 pawn
which is definitely a weak pawn it's
it's a backwards pawn you cannot advance
it these two guys are you know
preventing it from moving forward and
rook the a6 Magnus just defense and on
d6 we have Quinta III Quinta III is the
top move recommended by the engine
definitely some preparation this rook
after d1 followed by a Quinta III and
might be with an idea of maybe doubling
rooks here on the D file but other than
that I I don't really have a good
explanation and Queen to e3 other than
that it's the top move recommended by
the engine and that Magnus continues
shifting his knight over to c5 so Knight
to d7 and now a three by higher
efficient of putting pressure on the b4
pawn so Carlson has to react to this he
defends it with rook to b6 and we have
characters here so characters captures
and now rook to a4 again with a double
attack here on the pawn and now Magnus
goes for b3 it's it's a good move if it
works however if it doesn't then it
could be a liability if you will be able
to defend this pawn so how did krishna
goes back Knights to e 1 and now Knight
the c5 putting pressure on the rook and
also on the pawn here we have rook to a3
and now look the a6 again die
challenging this roof so here are high
recreational trades we have rook
captures on a6 Bishop characters and now
Bishop the F 1 and Bishop 2 F 1 is an
extremely strong move it's not it's not
an invitation to a repetition like
Bishop e7 followed by Bishop g2 Bishop
act a6 Bishop back to f1 but rather if
black persists with the dis to go after
d4 pawn Hari Krishna had Knights to d3
in mind and the point is if you go after
the pawn I would Knight captures any 410
Bishop g2 pins the night and after you
defended Queen a5 now rook to e1 you add
another attacker and now the knight has
to go back Knights the c5 and now you
trade everything last night captures
you're gonna get Bishop captures and g2
King captures D characters on c5 and
here white will be able to choose which
which point he fancies most and grab at
least one of them so that's why you
cannot go for the pawn with the dist or
ask for some sort of a
fold repetition so rogue back to c8 when
the knight moves you will put more
pressure on the c4 pawn and now Knight
to f3 the knight can now come to d2 and
put more pressure on the b3 porn while
adding more defense to the c4 pawn so
better back to b7 now Magnus goes for
the e4 pawn and Knight the d2 now
defending this is defending this and
also attacking on b3 so Bishop to c6 and
Magnus knows that at some point this
rook can come to a3 to add a third
attacker to the pond and he wants to be
able to defend it with Bishop to a4 so
here if you go for the pawn right away
with Knight captures here the problem is
Bishop to a4 also opens the night and
you will have a lot of problems here you
will not be able to withstand this
pressure so how do krishna goes to rook
to a 1 now you will not have any rook to
a for pinning tricks and now look the b8
Magnus defends the b3 point once again
and now rook the a3 Hydra Krishna goes
after the pawn and now how do you defend
it it's it's not at all clear thing is
you you cannot defend it you have to
play something else like King to g7 and
now the point is if you go after the
pawn let's say with the knight capture
son b3 then you've weakened d e4 pawn so
you basically defend it by waiting and
if one of the attackers attacks it then
you then you can win the e4 pawn
however Magnus decided to defend it with
Bishop to a4 and we've reached the
position from the thumbnail which
usually means that something very
magical happens here now what is
happening here what's the idea behind
Bishop a4 the idea is that a Hydra
Krishna has a brilliant move here that
could help him win the game however you
have to help him by pausing the video
and finding the best move in the
position while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting that you can win the two pieces
for the rook and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
it's rook captures an a4 I think is
after Knight characters which is the
only move you then have Queen to a7 with
a double attack under under rook and
under Knight sorry if I'm missing the
arrows lately I something seems to be
off with the mouse I think I'm gonna
have to get a new Mouse but yeah with a
double attack here
and you will not win the night and of
course if Luke defense it would look to
be for Queen to a5 again forces it back
and then you will pick up the night
you're up you have two pieces for the
rook which is in a position like this
should be winning since this is still a
weak pawn it's a backwards pawn you will
easily be able to even go after this
pawn so not really a problem there and
then once these two points start
marching forward should be should be a
fairly straightforward win
however hieroglyph not here went for h4
and Magnus blocked h5 by playing h5
himself he decided to block this idea so
h5 and now again rook captures and a4 is
in the position but now Bishop to e2 and
now after Bishop to e2 it's no longer in
the position here we have king to g7 by
Magnus and now the reason why this is no
longer in the position is exactly
because the bishop is a neat you for
example if you go for this now
characters characters and characters
then black has this insane move Knight
to c3 which offers the knight to start
pushing the past pawn here and also if
you just captured the roof let's say
Queen captures on b8 then you just
capture this guy with Czech and black
just will be able to get a threefold
repetition for example if King g2
neither for Czech opens up the King and
will be able to force a repetition or if
King moves you can then go knock Knights
to d3 to go after the B to pawn but here
basically if you capture them Queen
captures now attacks the night and after
the knight moves somewhere to help out
with the defense of the King then you
can check your with capture King g1
queen g4 check and if you block with the
night only then you catherine c4 defend
this pawn prepared this check followed
by characters here you create a fast
pawn and so on so very very dangerous
and another interesting thing after this
captures captures and Queen to a7 after
Knight to c3 you could also just capture
the night it is also possible but the
den black has Queen to d8 and now you
will push your passport and it's even if
it's playable it's impossible to
calculate this let's say Bishop d3
guards the the queening square and now
who knows what
what can happen here let's say you go
after the Queen Queen b7r okay one
checked King has to move or you can
block the the rook by also covering the
queening square and now who knows what's
happening here
so it's a rapid game a bit too much to
even try something like this so nice to
be won by Hari Krishna and now comes
Queen back to d8 so Magnus brings the
Queen back and also prepares just rook
to eight the Queen needs to guard the
rook on a a so Knight back to d2 again
puts pressure on the b3 pawn and now
rook the a8 and now preparing to move
the bishop so King H 2 and now Knights
the e6 again now the knife might come to
d4 from there the night will be
extremely strong so Knight f3 guarding
the d4 square twice and now Bishop the
c6 again putting pressure on the e4 pawn
and also if the rooks are traded off
which you should definitely do if you
allow this then Black gets a nice pass
pawn so you shouldn't allow it so real
capture Sunday 8 and the Queen captures
now not not allowing any any well you
you're basically offering the b3 point
for the e4 pawn and unless you want to
go back with something like night to d2
to guard e4 pawn and allow and
infiltration with Queen to a-1 then you
allow the trade so this is what Hari
Krishna does Queen captures and b3 with
best of capture Sonny 4 and now we have
Queen back the e3 now you cannot try
something else because the Queen and the
Queen and Bishop are attacking the
knight here so the Queen has to keep
defending so Queen back to e3 and now
just push her back to b7 and now you
could try b4 b5 let's say try and well
push your passport
it's what fast points are for however
had a traditional place c5 and it does
make sense if this captures then you
have Queen captures on e5 with check and
if the knight characters which is what
happens in the game then how the
traditional goes for Knight captures on
e5 with the idea that if pawn captures
then you can just capture with track and
win back your piece however
Magnus had something else in mind here
so feel free to pause the video once
again and try to find Carlson's idea
here while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations and finding a
beautiful addition soup and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show its
Queen to a-1 the strongest of in between
moves as it comes with the threat of
checkmate the bishop and queen are
nicely connecting on h1 so you have to
defend this and if you defend with with
a weird move then you will just lose
this night here so night back to f3 and
now comes Queen captures and b2 magnus
wins back his pawn and now he's also up
upon and it's a past deep on which is a
very dangerous pawn so here at Knight to
g5 now Hydra Krishna will try to go
after the f7 pawn and Bishop the d5
immediately adding another defender so
Bishop f3 we have Bishop captures by
Magnus Queen captures and now as the f7
point is under attack Queen to f6
immediately Magnus offers to trade down
into a knight and pawn endgame as he is
up upon and he is very confident in his
endgame skills as he should be he is the
world champion
so Queen back to e3 not avoiding the
trade of course and now Knight the e6
offering more trades which Hari Krishna
declines to Knight to f3 and now Queen
to f5 just grabbing more space maybe you
can start advancing your passport now
so King g-tube now the Queen can move as
the knight is defended and now Queen to
d5 again pinning the night with ideas of
maybe trading off soaking back to g1
unpinning and now King f6 shifting the
King over to e7 with Queen c3 check King
to e7 and now Queen back to III pinning
the night however Queen to c5 again
Magnus offers a queen trade with Queen
to d3 not accepting this in now Queen to
c1 check King g2 and Queen to c6 again
pinning the night here so king g1 Hart
accretion of course very happy would a
draw now he's down upon and well both
players are very low on time so Knight
the c5 attacking the Queen procuring to
maybe bring the knight closer and now
Queen III check with Queen
a4 again offering a queen trade and
again Hari Krishna has the decline Queen
C 3 we have Knight the e6 check and now
Queen to a3 pinning the pawn so you
cannot
pushing it King Teti eight unpinning now
with the idea that if Queen captures you
just lose the night since the night is
undefended so King G - and now comes g5
a very strong idea point is if you go
for something like this the put more
pressure on the night here then the
problem is you have Quinta a4 check and
you lose the night so you sorry that's a
bad arrow and you lose the night so you
have to be careful for ideas like this
so Magnus finds the very interesting g5
now if Queen captures just well we can
even show it
g4 attacks the pin piece and of course
it just wins the game so after g5 we
have king - g1 again unpinning and now
g4 pushes the knight back we have Knight
to g5 and now finally Magnus gets the
trade of the night so characters
captures and now Queen e1 with check now
it's a queen and ponent game which is or
which is one of the most difficult end
games to play regardless if you are up
upon or down upon
so Queen e1 check King to g2 or now
Queen back to e5 with check defending
and also attacking this however it's
more likely that you will go after this
pawn with the king so Queen a8 check
sorry but Queen eight check we have King
the e7 and now Queen to g8 trying to
keep keep an eye on the g5 point now
queenie for check King to g1 and out
Queen to g6 you have to force the White
Queen away from that pawn so Queen to c8
and now Queen to be one with check not
not going for this capture right away
then to allow some checks with Queen to
c7 first Magnus goes for Queen to be one
check King to h2 and now Queen the b6
guarding this pawn and now he wants to
advance this pawn to this pawn with the
king so King back to g2 and the now
Queen to c5 again offering a queen trade
but basically forcing the White Queen to
move Queen to g8 and now Queen to f5
again just getting the optimal square
for your queen we have Queen back to be
eight and then now Quinta e4 check again
sorry that's not a queen to Eve or check
again King to g1 and now d5 finally you
get
the the pawn push otherwise you you
might run into a 50 move rule as that we
haven't captured a piece or moved upon
so the five very nice now the 50 move
rule starts all over again we have Queen
to c7 with check King f8 and now Queen
to d8 with check with came to g7 and now
Queen to f6 with check so King to g8 you
have to play this to reach safety on h7
so clean back to d8
check King h7 and now Queen to f6
threatening to win the pawn but now
Queen to g6 and yes Queen and pawn end
games are this difficult we have Queen
back to a4 now guarding the g5 pawn but
now Queen to a six we have Queen to d4
and now finally King to g6 and here you
go after the point and here a very
interesting decision by Hari Krishna he
gives up the pawn right away and it's
the correct decision because if you try
Queen f4 to keep an eye on the pawn a
problem is well Quinta a1 check is a
very interesting idea but if you go to
g2 then Queenie 4 check will trade off
the Queen's however you can go to h2 and
then you don't have a queen trade
however after Queen to f4 you have this
Queen to b6 move which is just forcing
White's to play a move and the White has
no moves for example you you you can't
really move the Queen because just the
king will gobble up the pawn and if you
try something like King to f1 then just
check and wherever the King goes quinta
efore check will again trade the Queen's
off and if you try something like Queen
to d2 instead then again its Queen b1
check King to g2 and now Quinta efore
with check King g1 and Queen e5 now
guards the pawn and we'll pick up the g5
point finally so this is why re Krishna
decided to give up the pawn right away
he played King to f1 and now Magnus just
gobbles it up with the king and also now
he has Queen to g7 check which he goes
for Queen g7 check we have came to f5
and now Quinta h8 I'm going after the h5
pawn but Magnus now just doesn't care
about this point any more he gets King
to e4 in he wants to get the King to c2
again
with the weird arrows and start pushing
his past deep on so Queen captures on h5
but now King d3 we have Queen to h7 with
check King and now Queenie for just
blocking so Queen to h6 and now King to
c2 and Queen the c6 check now however
and now I don't even need to ask you to
pause the video because of course you'll
see the winning idea without even
pausing so congratulations everyone and
now you just block check and deliver
check so it's a it's a block delivering
check move and now it was of course in
this position and move 85 that pantalla
harikrishna resigned the game and a very
nice victory for Magnus Carlsen and of
course here you resign because after
characters and captures you now just
have a past point and white has no way
of dealing with this you are too too
slow to even start consider pushing your
pawns and after this and this the the
pawn just now promotes the Queen and
it's very straightforward win so after
this Queen to c4 check Hari Krishna
resigned and Wow
I mean what a game so he had that one
moment will actually two moments he
could have he could have sacrificed that
worked for two pieces and have a pretty
much a winning game but he didn't he
didn't spot it after Magnus played
Bishop day for there was rock character
Sunday for and then Quint a7 but you
have to take advantage of the
opportunity that the world champion
presents you so once again I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank
Alexandra door no hana tomochka
yeah gana Sheshadri Chris sides and
Philipp graphic for a confucian to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the chasuble
masters checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and of course whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and do check
out the two links in the description
below see you soon